[Music]
but for me
both for cute and adorable grover i am
pro abc's and four one two threes plus i
promise i have no skeletons in my closet
i do not even have one in my body
hey grover what are you doing oh hello
there sal khan i am just running for
president of the united states of
america i heard there was an upcoming
election so i figured ah why not well
that's great grover yeah maybe we can
help more people vote oh that would be
terrific
so exactly how many votes do i need to
win
well you know about the electoral
college right of course sal baby i know
exactly what the
electrical electoral electoral colleges
great so why don't we explain it
together for those who don't know oh my
certainly what a brilliant idea
um
[Music]
why don't you start us off
sure
in a direct democracy i as a citizen
will vote for a candidate and whichever
candidate has the most popular votes in
the country they will become president
but we do not have a direct democracy we
have an indirect democracy so what
happens is is i vote in my state i live
in california and whichever candidate
gets the most votes in california will
get all of california's 55 electoral
votes and that's true in most states
whoever gets the most votes in that
state gets all of the votes for that
state and that number comes from the
number of congress people california has
um i i am not following you so how can i
explain it in a way that you might
understand chickens
i know chickens chickens they are my
biggest demo
okay chickens so instead of electors
we'll say chickens instead of the
electoral college i'll say chicken
college okay that that can follow okay
the number of chicken votes for each
state is equal to the number of congress
people for that state
in every state
yes from california to the new york
island from the redwood forest to the
gulf stream waters yes the 50 states
and so there are a total of
538 chicken votes in the chicken college
for example florida has 29 chicken votes
and that's the same as the 29 congress
people that they have two senators and
27 representatives oh hello there
chickens
okay then so how do i
candidate grover win the presidency well
since there are 538 chicken votes in
total you just have to get more than
half of those more than half
hmm let me see here uh
one carry the two divided by eight
grover we know the actual number you
just have to get at least
chicken votes in the chicken college
just
270 chickens i can do that 300 chickens
just crossed the road to hear me speak
at the rally oh great do you have your
speech oh yeah it's right there
did they put it dude
ah i'll just wing it
bye so bye grover
now get out there and vote
you